[Music]
in thug life news submitted by
California love state official was fired
for loving Tupac too much fired for
loving Tupac too much
how is that even possible what if he was
talking about [ __ ] and [ __ ] and he
had a bunch of girls like in there and
he was like how do you on it that's
that'll get you fired yeah that'll get
you fired
what he was a white he was a what was
his job oh so he was a director of
Iowa's Department of Human Services I
picture like Mike Huckabee with like a
[ __ ] Tupac bandana around his
forehead or he just walks around with a
Tupac hologram or his boxers are always
out you imagine him with like a Tupac
bandana you know how you used to rap it
down to that way yeah they're women and
he goes the blacker the berry the
sweeter the juice baby he didn't even do
anything wrong though yeah you don't
even know the story I do know the stock
oh yeah yeah I read this article II
didn't do anything wrong well Ted tell
us what happened
oh he so the most the last straw here
was that he message to all 4,300 staff
members I'm talking about how like you
know have a happy Father's Day and while
you're celebrating fathers day it's also
Tupac's birthday that's [ __ ] doe the
email with two [ __ ] face in it that's a
good picture to party picture that guy
doing that it's to know that his search
history and I'd like to park in it
because he looks like he likes Hall &
Oates or some shade you know yeah yeah
email says you have already received my
email reminding you that this Sunday is
Father's Day I am sure you are already
aware that this Sunday June 16th is also
Tupac's birthday parentheses he would be
40 today if you were alive so horse Oh
young he was he would have been 48 so of
course I will be celebrating both
Father's Day and Tupac's birthday I hope
you all enjoy the day as well and take
the time to enjoy one of his songs
hearts parentheses hard to believe he
has been gone for almost 2000 damn it's
about Tupac
here is an inspirational quote by him
you wonder why they call you [ __ ]
you wonder why they call you [ __ ] I
betcha [ __ ] [ __ ] you fat
[ __ ]
the quote is pay no mind to those who
talk behind your back
it simply means that you are two steps
ahead and then at the end of it though
that's really good which is really
ironic now that he got fired he wouldn't
he do wrong and someone complained for
the frequent Tupac emails feel so bad
from that's just this game so when the
media group they ended up printing out
his Tupac emails like all of the ones
that he has been came up to like 350
peace he's a mega [ __ ] fan when I get
that many employers I'm a son of Eminem
emails all day every day I'm not working
for bothering you you look like Eminem
fan or like it doesn't you don't look
weird no it looks like she can like
hip-hop she's young like it's it's like
it's not as weird as a grandma like
Eminem yeah like a 67 year old person
yeah like I don't picture this guy he's
beach boy I actually pictured this guy
hating Tupac like he looks like the guy
that's like you should have [ __ ]
listen to this yeah yeah maybe maybe
this is his appearance because that's
what everyone else in his world is
mmm-hmm
break out what it's like when he goes
home he and puffy like all he wears like
a do-rag and like a wife beater at 5:00
p.m. he's just like finally but at the
end of that email he wrote oh by the way
on his birthday I will have finished my
second full year of serving as your
director these two years have flown by
and has been absolute all such a
dedicated and committed group of people
thanks for all you do
that's [ __ ] up okay okay if what if
he's being a politician for a very urban
area and he just like wants to connect
like right now he's in
you don't think there's a ghetto in Iowa
I don't know I don't think so I think
the people they are under him are their
racist yeah yeah are they racist I
didn't maybe they only know the bad
stuff about Tupac like he's gang
affiliation and all that stuff and they
don't know what he actually did well it
was like for the colleagues they were
just saying like it was just too
annoying why would he get fired yeah
they should just tell them like yo back
up on the quote yeah because what if you
was quoting Abraham Lincoln all day
would they feel that way I know right no
so the thing about is him being fired
they're saying that the governor ended
up kind of like leading hit like pushing
or was the wording maybe the governor
was a big e fan it was an inside job it
was like we gotta take this guy down
I know dude don't worry do it but it was
something like you know they were pretty
much like pushing him to resign kind of
thing cuz he was to West Coast Iowa he's
too liberal thinking yeah so they're
saying that they haven't they won't
disclose the reason why which is
actually against the law because there's
no real reason there's no credibility is
he Republican or Democrat I don't know
he should just move to California no be
happy of the director here we would we
would accept you oh they should say like
R or D in front of his name or is it a
she oh yeah Kim no no hit yeah the guy
that got fired I was actually a girl
governor I was a girl that guy's job
seems like it it's not part of any party
it's like the head of a DMV like oh so
he's he's got a represented he's a yeah
he just works in the government but he's
not a policy resources director
Department of Human Resources iOS
Department oh ok for some odd reason I
thought he was a politician oh and then
the governor Cameron Reynolds she's a
Republican if of Reynolds foil she comes
from that family yeah so much prestige
Dean Reynolds of Reynolds Boyle
you may have cooked with me before do
you think like he was like I recommend
you guys to listen to a tupac song for
today and you have like the whole staff
like I don't even know what to pocket so
they type it in I didn't actually play
the music in his office as well and they
were just like dude that's so dope
so two years of bombarding his
colleagues missions abroad yeah so
you're saying like prevalence sorry for
Valentine's Day he's cher like a love
line and and then like also an image of
to Punk as well and he also would use
his legs frequently it's time for us to
have the people that have started making
some changes that's one of that [ __ ]
what if he was like he's like uh
disciplining you he's like yo I ain't a
killer but don't push me just like the
sweetest or that's what gettin put that
no I want to see like I feel like I want
to say inner cut of like old concert
footage with like a zooming in on him in
the background he's been a mega fan yeah
they make like thug life cookies to any
pasta man that's exactly the other thing
this man is a door I love awesome you
made cookies yeah what have you just a
troll like she does this as like a joke
I think it's like Nikki like he's but
she's just in there she's in it yeah cuz
350 pages of emails cuz I feel like we
all went through like a Tupac phase in I
did it but a lot of us did in the late
90s early to even onto the early 2000s
we were just waiting for like another
dead song to come out like oh like an
unreleased being gone oh yeah uh-huh
that's true wait he died in 96 I was on
that I was on the borderline like I knew
the songs but I was it it was like from
the kids that were older than me
mmm that'd be me and Joe probably yeah
we were in elementary school oh damn
yeah 96 is when he passed all would be
12 oh that's right junior high
kindergarten Oh God I was in third or
fourth grade yeah I was like third or
fourth grade I found him in oh I was
like in elementary when I heard about he
was still alive anyway I found about it
tubes with a people like you don't know
who to pockys I'm like I don't know and
then everyone was like oh my god I'm
like [ __ ] you I was like in third or
fourth grade it was like that was two
days ago when I found out I was pissed
too because in Dibley oh I heard a Tupac
my Becca has a funny name is everyone
always made fun of my name because this
funny Barton not like Barton and Tupac
they're both funny names how come you
like Tupac but not Barton personally why
you why don't you make fun of Tupac did
I was later be I don't know when full
name is Barton Barton yeah yeah I
learned of two pocket in college that's
how old but you were never really into
hip-hop right so that's why I hated it
your brother never bumped it no won't be
there the NWA teairra you got to
remember like there's like 10 almost 20
years older than me so Tupac is like
they're like little NAS or some of this
yeah I guess but the Tupac's actually
good and when the use Hawkeye's name and
call Barton are you like triggered which
grants guy and Avengers his name is
Barton Clint Barton yeah it was like
doors like Barton Barton I'm just mad at
those kids that picked on you cuz he
fell bartender to a bar - oh wow there
are plenty back then bartender I thought
Hart said he gave me a two pack of beer
yeah I thought Tupac was like 2pac yes
when I was a kid I thought away she pack
not you shaker yeah that was too bad -
yeah you know the they were parks
those that yeah that was really little
were you are they 96 you're in
kindergarten yeah oh man I'd you're a
fetus
no yeah I was yes yeah you guys are the
same age so kindergarten I didn't know
holiday was it's right we were 12
yeah we were in junior high get in
junior high so we were probably good
seventh grader probably an eighth grade
or something bein your cool gia mid or
16 that would
and he's gonna be in six we were bump in
sublime were yes yeah I like to born to
don't prank this Sansa yeah I feel like
all beach cities bumped so so why I met
during that time and still today I was
about the sublime life cuz Bradley died
around the same time yes he did and I
had just discovered sublime and then he
passed I was like what the [ __ ] what
about Wade what about Kurt Cobain yeah
those around I found out about Bradley
and Kurt dying when I was a freshman in
high school
see all the good [ __ ] died man know
everyone know heroin was in style it's
making a comeback now it was like in
style back then that's not a game out
and I was like man grunge culture and
heroin all Bardot sings